Verantwortungsvolles Computing bedeutet,
Quantencomputing so zu entwickeln,
dass man sich seiner Leistungsfähigkeit bewusst ist
und mögliche Auswirkungen im Blick hat. Wenn wir von Verantwortung sprechen,
meinen wir, Technologie zu entwickeln und einzusetzen,
die auf klar definierten Prinzipien basiert, um mögliche Schäden zu verhindern
und zu minimieren –
während gleichzeitig Lösungen gefördert werden, die proaktiv
inklusiv und verantwortlich sind. Bei IBM
handeln wir seit Jahrzehnten aus einem Verantwortungsbewusstsein
gegenüber der Gesellschaft heraus. Heute verstehen wir uns als Katalysator,
der die Welt besser macht. Das bedeutet,
wir müssen die Auswirkungen der Technologien bedenken,
die wir entwickeln und zum Einsatz bringen.
Während wir diese neue Technologie entwickeln,
werden die Entscheidungen, die wir heute treffen, die Zukunft prägen.
Und diese Entscheidungen
haben das Potenzial, einen enormen Einfluss auf die Gesellschaft zu haben.
Du musst zum Beispiel entscheiden, ob du eine Anwendung entwickeln willst, die nur wenigen Beteiligten nützt,
oder eine, die
ein gesellschaftliches Problem lösen könnte.
Wir hoffen, dass du als Kunde in der Lage bist,
über eine verantwortungsvolle Entwicklung des Quantencomputings nachzudenken.
Verantwortungsvolles Denken kann deinem Unternehmen helfen, Vertrauen aufzubauen –
bei Investoren und Verbrauchern
und gleichzeitig einen Ruf für Integrität
und Wertschätzung bei deinen Mitarbeitern
und Kunden aufzubauen. Auf der anderen Seite
schützt es dich vor schlechter Presse, Bußgeldern
und Strafen. In diesem Video
stellen wir wichtige Aspekte der Verantwortung vor,
die du mit deinem Team besprechen solltest,
während du Quantencomputing
und seine Anwendungen erkundest. Beim Quantencomputing bedeutet
verantwortungsvolles Denken und Handeln,
einer Reihe von Prinzipien
und Werten zu folgen, die deine Entwicklung leiten –
und den Einsatz der Technologie.
Das bedeutet zum Beispiel, transparent zu sein
– sowohl über die Grenzen als auch über die Möglichkeiten
des Quantencomputings. Wir haben Formulierungen
in unseren Verträgen, die IBM Quantum-Kunden verpflichten,
unsere Systeme verantwortungsvoll zu nutzen
und sie nicht
für unerlaubte oder illegale Zwecke einzusetzen.
Wir nennen das unsere Klauseln zur
verantwortungsvollen und akzeptablen Nutzung.
Diese Formulierungen beeinflussen bereits, wie unsere Kunden denken,
wenn es um die Entwicklung von Quantenanwendungen
für ihre Anwendungsfälle geht. Wir können
auch die Richtung des Quantencomputings mitgestalten,
indem wir entscheiden, welche Anwendungen wir verfolgen –
für Entwicklung und Beschleunigung.
Um mögliche verantwortungslose Nutzung
unserer Technologie zu verhindern, haben wir außerdem robuste IBM Quantum
Safe-Technologie entwickelt. Wenn du darüber nachdenkst, wie
und wofür du Quantencomputing einsetzen möchtest,
sprich realistisch über deine Erwartungen
an das Quantencomputing und über die Zeitrahmen,
in denen du Quantencomputing integrieren möchtest.
Stelle Quantencomputing nicht
als mysteriös dar – erkläre es stattdessen realistisch
als Computing-Hardware,
die den Regeln der Quantenphysik folgt.
Achte darauf, dass dein Anwendungsfall für Quantencomputing
proaktiv inklusiv ist
und alle potenziellen Beteiligten berücksichtigt,
um das Ausmaß
möglicher negativer gesellschaftlicher Auswirkungen zu bestimmen.
Stell sicher, dass du klare Prinzipien
und Werte für die Erkundung deines Anwendungsfalls
und die Entwicklung definiert hast. Danke,
dass du zugeschaut hast. Wir hoffen,
dass du, wenn du nützliches Quantencomputing in die Welt bringst,
auch darüber nachdenkst, wie du das verantwortungsvoll tun kannst.
Das das